ก็
สวัสดีค่ะครูฟ้า
สวัสดีค่ะครูหญิงสวัสดีค่ะนักเรียนสวัสดี
ค่ะนักเรียนทุกคน
วันนี้ก็เป็นยังไงคะกลับมาพบกับครูฟ้า
แล้วก็กูหญิงนายปีหน้า Class ไทยค่ะค่ะ
น้องไปหยังกะฟ้าฟ้าหญิงดีกว่าดูดีกับก็
รูปฟ้าคะวันนี้วันอะไรคะ
วันนี้วัน
ศุกร์
ค่ะวันนี้วันศุกร์
วันศุกร์ที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันศุกร์ที่ 18 ค่ะเดือนอะไรคะเดือน
กุมภาพันธ์ค่ะจะปีพต
อะไรคะและพ.ต.
2565 ปีคศอะไรคะปีคศ 2
022 ค่ะค่ะเมื่อวานนี้วันอะไรคะ
เมื่อวันนี้วันพฤหัสบดี
วันที่เท่าไหร่คะวันที่ 17 ค่ะค่ะดีเดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
ปีพตต
2565 ปีคศ
ปีค.ศ
2022 ค่ะพรุ่งนี้วันอะไรคะ
พรุ่งนี้วันเสาร์ค่ะค่ะวันที่เท่าไหร่คะ
วันที่ 19 ค่ะเดือน
เดือนกุมภาพันธ์
AE พ.คก็ขอ
2565 ปีคศ
2  022 ค่ะค่ะวันนี้ก็วันศุกร์แล้วเนาะ
แล้วตอนนี้เวลากี่โมงครับครูฟ้า
ตอนนี้เวลา
13:00 น
บ่ายโมงกี่นาทีคะไปโมงกี่นาที
บ่ายโมง 18 นาทีค่ะบ่ายโมง 18 นาทีน้องก็
เป็นเวลากลางวันเป็นเวลากลางวัน
แล้วอเมริกากี่โมงคะครูหญิงอเมริกาเนี่ย
นะคะก็จะเป็นเวลา
กลางคืนหรอตีหนึ่งสิบแปดนาทีนี่ค่ะตี
หนึ่งสิบแปดนาทีนอนเป็นเวลากลางคืนใช่ไหม
ซื้อวันนี้นะคะครูฟ้าคุยมีแต่ก็ก็มีเกมมา
เล่นกับครูฟ้าอีกแล้ว
เกมอะไรคะผู้หญิงเกมเนี่ยนะคะก็จะมีคำถาม
ครูหญิงจะมีคำถามเนาะแล้วก็ครูฟ้าอันนี้
กูฟ้านะคะครูฟ้านะอ่ะครูอ่ะครูฟ้าและก็
ต้องคิด
ใช่ไหมคิดหน้า
ปากต้องที่สุดคิดว่าที่ครูหญิงถามเนี่ย
มันผู้หญิงเอามีของสีจะมีให้ครูฟ้าดูให้
กูฟ้าเนี่ยดูในกูฟ้าเนี่ยดูเสร็จก็ต้อง
คิดว่าเอ้ยอันนี้เนี่ยใช้ทำอะไร
[เพลง]
อันนี้ไม่ใช่คำถามร้อนนี้ครูฟ้าน่ะรู้จัก
แน่นอนนะคะหายแล้วพี่หาไม่เจอออกนี้ค่ะ
เสร็จแล้วค่ะคุณครูฟ้า / อันนี้เนี่ยโทร
ฟ้า
ครูฟ้ารู้จักเนาะอันนี้นะคะ
แล้วอันนี้เนี่ยขายทำอะไร
อันนี้เนี่ยใช้ตัดเล็บค่ะ
คลิปตัดสมัยสัตว์อัดอัดอัดเล็กส่งเล็บเลย
เล็บใช่ไหมยาวแล้วก็อันนี้
ตัดเล็บสัตว์อันนี้เนี่ยที่ใช้ตัดเล็บเรา
เรียกว่าอะไรคะ
เราเรียกว่า
กรรไกรตัดเล็บเออเพราะฉะนั้นกรรไกรตัด
เล็บใช้ทำอะไร
กรรไกรตัดเล็บใช้ตัดเล็บค่ะจะไปตัดเล็บ
อันนี้เป็นตัวอย่างน้อง example นะคะ
เดี๋ยวอันนี้จะเป็นเกมจริงๆก็
คุยสลิกของนะคะให้ครูฟ้าเนี่ยดูให้ผมฟ้า
ดู
เอาอย่างแรกเลยละกันคิดว่าในครูฟ้าน่าจะ
อาจจะรู้ว่าคืออะไร
อะไรอันนี้คือฟ้าอันนี้เป็นเป็นสแตนเลสนะ
เราก็มีรูหนึ่งรู 2 รูอันนี้เนี่ยครูฟ้า
ดูแล้วคิดว่าของอันนี้ใช้ทำอะไร
กูพาคิดว่า
ใช้
เปิดกระป๋อง
เปิดกระโปรงเปิดเปิดเปิดเปิด
กระป๋องเปิดนี้หรอฟ้า
ข่าวแบบนี้ใช่ไหม
กระป๋องแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะๆค่ะอ๋อแล้วจะเอา
อันนี้เนี่ย
แล้วก็เปิดเสื้ออ่ะหนูเล็กของมั้ยที่เปิด
กระป๋องอ่ะเคยคะใช่ค่ะ
เพราะว่ากระป๋องบางกระป๋องใช่มั้ยอย่าง
เงี้ยอันนี้มีที่เปิดก็โอเคไม่ต้องใส่อัน
นี้ทำไมแต่ถ้าก็บอกเนี่ยไม่มีตรงนี้ก็ใช้
อันนี้เนี่ยเปิดกระป๋องเอา
ครูฟ้านะคะคิดเนี่ยคิดนะนี้นะอ่าครูฟ้า
เนี่ยคิด Hook
คิดถึงผัวถูกหึ 10%  50% ถูกขีด
50%
[เพลง]
6  50% ก็คือใช้เปิดใช้เปิด
มีแต่ไม่ใช่เปิดกระป๋องไม่ใช่เหมือน
กระป๋องอันนี้เนี่ยมันใช้เปิด
แบบนี้ค่ะขวดโค้กที่มีฝาแบบนี้
แล้วก็คิดว่าฟ้าต่อใช้ฝั่งนี้ใช่ไหมเงียบ
หน้าเป็นที่เปิดขวดเนาะเราเรียกว่าว่าที่
เปิดขวดน้องเอาไว้เปิดขวดก็นี้เป็นขวดนะ
คะไม่ใช่กระป๋องอันนี้เป็นขวดนะคนโค้กหึ
เปิดใช่ก็พูดผิดอ้าผู้ค้าคิดกูกะเห็นไหม
ฮะโอเคค่ะไม่เป็นไรไม่เป็นไรโทรฟ้าต่อไป
นะคะของชิ้นที่ 2
วันนี้แล้วกันอันนี้
อันนี้เนี่ยเป็นขวดเธอเป็นขวดแล้วก็มีฝา
นะป๊าบเปิดบนี้นะคะครูฟ้านะคิดว่าอันนี้
เนี่ยใช้ทำอะไร
กูฟ้าคิดว่า
ใช้
เหมือน
ใช้ทาผ้าเหรอ
เหมือนเกล้าหรอไม่ใช่กาวสิเหมือนแม้ว่า
เอาไว้เขาเรียกอะไรกูฟ้าแป๊บนึงนะฮะ
เนี่ยนจะสมองเม้นท์
โดเรมอน
เดี๋ยวครูฟ้าเนี่ยหารูปให้ดูว่าคิดว่าขวด
นี้นะคะนี่มันเขียนเป็นภาษาญี่ปุ่นนะถ้า
นักเรียนเป็นคนญี่ปุ่นอาจจะเข้าใจว่าอัน
นี้เนี่ยใช้ทำอะไรรู้ฟ้าเป็นคนไทย
ฟ้าไม่เข้าใจภาษาญี่ปุ่นนักไฟฟ้าก็เลยไม่
รู้ใช้ไปทำอะไรอ่ะครูฟ้าคิดว่าใช้ทำอะไร
นะ
เหมือนอันเนี้ยขอ
สมมติว่าเสื้อใช่ไหมมีจุดหรอมีจุดสีดำ
แล้วก็ซักซักๆไม่ได้ก็เอาเนี้ยถ้าแล้วก็
รอรอรอ
ๆแล้วก็ซักได้อ๋อยกไฮเตอร์ใช่ไหมไฮเตอร์
เอ้อ
นี่เลย
10 ชา
คิดว่าคะ Way ใช่อันนี้เอาไว้ไม่ได้เอา
ไว้ซักผ้าน้องไม่ได้เอาไว้ซักผ้าอันนี้
เนี่ยนะครับของซินนี้นะคะใช้ทาเหมือนกัน
แต่ว่าทาบาปจะไม่ตรงนี้
จริงๆถ้าครูฟ้าเนี่ยนั่งทำงานคอมพิวเตอร์
แล้วก็ขอกูอ้วนหรือว่าตรงนี้ถ้าใช้ถอย
เนี่ยโอ๊ยหรือว่าหัวปวดครูฟ้าก็เอานี้
เนาะเปิดมันจะแบบเหมือนเป็นมิ้นน่ะค่ะก็
ไม่รู้ว่าเรียกว่าอะไรเหมือน
เคาน์เตอร์เพนเลยเงี้ยทาทา
ทา
แล้วเราก็จะรอมันก็จะแบบเย็นๆจะเหมือน
พาราเซตามอลแต่ไม่ได้กินเนาะค่ะเอาไว้
ขึ้นมา
ออฟฟิศซินโดรมใะเร็งนี้ชายอ่ะค่ะเราไม่
ว่าอย่าฮะว่าคิดว่าดีโอโดแรนท์นะไม่ใช่
ไหมใช่ค่ะเราเรียกยาทาแก้ปวดใช่ไหมอย่าง
ในรูปเนี่ยคนนี้เนี่ยโอ้โห
ปวดเกาะถาใช้ทาแก้ปวด
ทาแก้ปวด
ฟ้าคุยชอบมาก
คนที่ฝนหลังมันก็ชอบ
ต่อไปค่ะครูหน้าม้าปัดดีขึ้นแล้วก็ฟ้าจะ
รู้เนาะอันนี้คือฟ้านะคะเป็นแท่นเป็นสี่
เหลี่ยมเนาะสี่เหลี่ยมแบนๆแล้วก็มีเรื่อง
นึงสีเหลืองครึ่งนึงดูเป็นแบบหินนะคะเป็น
สี่เหลี่ยมครูฝาคิดว่าอันนี้เนี่ยใช้ทำ
อะไรอ่ะ
จะ
ใช้
ใช้ทำอะไรวางโทรศัพท์บ่
ขอมีโทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมพรุ่งนี้โทรศัพท์
โนเกียเหรอคะมีโทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมคะแล้วก็วาง
โทรศัพท์ไอ้ห่าว่างโทรศัพท์กูฟ้าคุณถูก
50% อีกแล้วผิด
50% ใช้วางเนี่ยถูกแล้วแต่ไม่ได้วาง
โทรศัพท์
ว่างอะไรใช่ไหมใช้วางแก้ว
วางแก้วมั้ยพี่แก้วน้ำแล้วก็วางแก้วนะคะ
อันนี้เนี่ยเราก็เลยเรียกว่าจานเปิดบ้าง
คะจะไปธุระจานรองแก้วชาญรองแก้วที่รอง
แก้ว
มันมีน้ำก็วางตรง If ใช่ไหมคะที่รองแก้ว
ใช้
วางแก้ว
เลยต่อไปค่ะครูฟ้า
ต่อไปอันนี้จะกันอันนี้แล้วกัน
เป็นแค่หูจะอันนี้เป็นไม้นะคะเป็นไม้
เนี่ยสูงขึ้นมาแบบนี้แล้วก็ข้างล่างเนี่ย
มีเหมือนหินเนาะเป็นวงกลมๆครูฟ้าคิดว่า
อันนี้เนี่ยใช้ทำอะไร
ปิดก็เป็นเหมือน
เฮ้ยอานี้ใช้
เอ้าก็เป็นของเล่น
คิดว่าอะไรอ่ะก็ใช้
แขวน
แขวนนะ
แผนมั่ว
on เวลาที่อุ้ยหลุดนะผู้หญิงทอมหลุดอ่ะ
เรามีหมวก
ไม่เป็นไรเนาะโอเคเรามีหมวกใช่ไหมคะบวกนะ
หมวกแก๊ปเนี่ยนะคะแล้วก็เวลาถึงบ้านก็
สีทำ 6 หลุดนะคะเอาหมวกวางใช้วางหมวดใช้
แขวนบวก
ไม่ใช่ค่ะ
[ปรบมือ]
โทรหาย่าแล้วอยากรู้ไหมใช้ทำอะไรแต่ผู้
หญิงทำบุตรอยู่
มันใช้ทำอะไรนะผู้หญิงอันนี้เนี่ยโป้ขา
ขายวางทิชชู่
จึงสู้สายดึงที่สู้มันก็จะหมุนๆๆเจ้าหญิง
ทำหลุดนะคะใช้วางทิชชู่เราเรียกอะไรอ่ะ
ที่วางทิชชู่
เนาะก็ที่ว่าสู้ใช้วางทิชชู่
ภาษาอันนี้ฟังทิชชู่ล่ะ
ยาวไงเวลาดึงใช่มั้ยเวลามันอยู่ในนี้
อย่างเงี้ยมันก็จะหมุนๆหมุนยาวอย่างนี้
ได้นะเราก็เลยเอาไว้วางทิชชู
ในห้องครัวเวลาทำอาหารอะแม่
โอเคค่ะต่อไปค่ะครูป๊า
ต่อมาครูภาษาอังกฤษว่าอันนี้เนี่ยนะคะอ่ะ
คะอันนี้หน้าตาอันเนี้ยเป็นแบบเหมือนทรง
รูปทรงแบบเนี้ยกูฟ้าคิดว่าไทยทำอะไร
คุณ
วัดไม่ได้อ้ะ
มาคิดว่าใช้
ใช้ทำอะไร
เป็นอากาศหรอคะออกซิเจนหรออ๋อฟ้าคิดว่า
ใช้ทำออกซิเจน
สวยแบบที่นี่แล้วก็อาจจะกดๆแล้วก็มี
ออกซิเจนแล้วก็เปิดแล้วก็
ขอใช้ทำออกซิเจน
มันใช่มั้ยคิดค่าหวยใช่ไม่ได้ใช้ทำ
ออกซิเจนเครื่องอันนี้นะคะอันนี้เนี่ย
คือนี่ค่ะอ่ะที่
ใช้ทำกาแฟ
อันนี้ไม่รู้เลยค่ะ
กดกดตรงนี้กดตรงไหนตรงวงกลมๆตรงนี้ใช่ไหม
คะแล้วมันก็จะมีกาแฟออกมาเป็นกาแฟแบบ S
เพรสโซ่เราเรียกว่าเครื่องทำกาแฟ
ผู้หญิงผู้หญิงดูพี่ก็ไม่เข้าใจเหมือนกัน
นะว่าอันนี้เนี่ยใช้ทำกาแฟ
ไม่ดื่มกาแฟผู้เขาก็เลยไม่รู้นะคะอ่ะต่อ
ไปค่ะนี้ผู้ก็อาจจะรู้ก็ได้
อันนี้เป็นกล่องเนาะกรอบตาเจ้าของผู้หญิง
เปิดก่อนนะฮะแล้วก็ข้างในเนี่ยก็จะมี
อันนี่
ทำไงก็คืออะไรเดี๋ยวกูเยอะเนี่ย
อยู่ที่บอกเธอไม่ได้อ้ะแบบนี้เท่ากับอา
วีฟ a แล้วก็ B เนาะมีสองฝั่งครูฟ้าคิด
ว่าอันนี้เนี่ยอันนี้นะคะใช้ทำอะไร
ใช้แคะหูใช่มั้ยใช่แค่พรุ่งนี้
ช่วง
อันนี้หน้าตาเป็นแบบใช้แค่หูแล้วก็ไม่
ต้องชิงเนาะคุณเนี่ยนักเรียนอาจจะใช้แค่
หูหรือว่าปั่นจะไปปั่นหู
เสร็จแล้ว
ล้างแล้วก็เก็บมาเขาเรียกอะไรคะพี่ปั่นหู
ไม้ปั่นหู
ไม้ปั่นไม้แคะหูไม้แค่หูหูไม้ปั่นหูก็ได้
เพราะเราจะแบบแบบนี้เวลาเราทำก็เกิดนี้
ใช่ไหมอันนี้เราเรียกว่าการปั่นนะครับถ้า
เราจะปั่นที่นี่ใช่มั้ยที่หูก็ปั่นหูราคา
ฝันหู
[เพลง]
เก่งมากค่ะครูฟ้า
ผู้หญิงเก็บไม่ได้นะคะโอเค
ชิ้นตอบชิ้นสุดท้ายนะเชียรสุดท้ายนี้คิด
ว่ากูปลาอาจจะรู้
อ่ะอันนี้ค่ะครูป๊าป๊าเป็นไม้เป็นไม้ 2
อัน
นี้นะเป็นไม้ 2 อันแล้วก็เอามาได้ต่อใส่
ด้วยกันได้ครูบาคิดว่าไม้อันเนี้ยไทยทำ
อะไร
ไฟล์คิดว่า
ไม้อันนี้ใช้วางโทรศัพท์ค่ะอ๋อมีโทรศัพท์
ใช่ไหมแล้วก็วางชั้นวางโทรศัพท์วาง
โทรศัพท์เกมส์
ดูหนังสวยแบบนี้ใช่ไหมคะแล้วเราก็มี
โทรศัพท์เนาะแต่เราก็วางไว้ตอนนี้ก็ได้
ค่ะ
ถ้าเราก็ดูสวยดูใช้วางโทรศัพท์นะคะโอ้ยมา
ดูซิมีอะไรบ้างเราก็จะมีที่วางโทรศัพท์
ใช้ทำอะไรคะภูฟ้าใช้วางโทรศัพท์ค่ะจะมี
โทรศัพท์ใช่ไหมใช้วางโทรศัพท์
ส่วนอันนี้นะคะอันนี้เนี่ย
ใช้ทำอะไรคะ
ใช้
ปั่นหูไม้ปั่นหูใช้ปั่นหูมาหา
อันนี้เนี่ยที่รองแก้วและจานรองแก้วใช้ทำ
อะไรคะ
ใช้รองแก้วค่ะกะไปรองแก้วว่าใช้วางแก้ว
เต็ม
ที่เปิดขวดใช้ทำอะไรคะที่เปิดขวดใช้เปิด
ขวดค่ะเปิดขวดโค้กนะคะ
ยาทาแก้ปวดใช้ทำอะไรคะ
ใช้ทาแก้ไขทาหลังคา
แล้วก็อันนี้เนาะ
เอาผู้หญิงทำหลุดเนี่ยนะคะที่วางทิชชู่
ใช่ไหมคะใช้ทำอะไรคะ
ใช้วางทิชชู่ค่ะค่ะตอบแล้วสุดท้ายนะคะ
เครื่องทำกาแฟ
ใช้ทำอะไรคะใช้ทำกาแฟค่ะใส่ทำกาแฟนแบบนี้
มาค่ะก็นี้ก็เป็นของใช้ใช่ไหมคะที่เรามา
เล่นเกมว่าใช้ทำอะไรน้องนักเรียนเนี่ยทุก
หรือว่าผิดอ่ะก็คอมเม้นท์บอกเราได้เนาะ
วันนี้เราสองคนก็ไปก่อนนะคะแล้วเจอกัน
ใหม่วิดีโอหน้าค่ะบ๊ายบายสวัสดีค่ะอ่ะ